all right just give me your quick dirty
tees for the season ahead Paulie and I
having sex on camera
yes told you 60 days boil alert famously
single why do this show well so that you
can get coupled up like these soon
you're falling in love with me between
you now I got calling in love with me so
your old will see the love story play
out this season
but what can you tell us about it yeah
and brandy you watched it unfold yes I
did it was it was hot and heavy and fast
and aggressive I mean we had therapy
sessions on when it would be appropriate
for us to sleep together like literally
the whole group would have a discussion
about what was too soon
well it is very murky territory you're
all there yeah well 24 hours a day scam
really there and we're kissing is camera
honest right so it's like you want to
you know we already have a sex date now
yeah symma but but but a network has it
sir yes so we know I can't find a girl
that wants me for the right reasons have
you been in love I don't think so cuz I
would know right I can't imagine you
expected you would find your soul mate
by going on this show I don't think so
you know what's funny I spent my entire
life in front of the camera it feels
almost like right for me personally you
have met families they met my daughter
my mother oh yes it's real deal
beautiful family you might be a part of
it soon I am a part of it do you guys
see marriage down the line we see
marriage I love this do that right Mora
like went what is the timing of our
lives more
like wondering if we're each other's
person you know I enjoy being around her
I mean guys like I'm just taking it all
in this we're not watching a moment
happen here